we have a perfect segue to talk about
Syria so there's a lot going on we did
this last week everybody absolutely
everybody thought we were going to war
Obama said we were going to war a lot of
people including myself were giving him
a lot of crap for not going to Congress
which then he decided he was going to do
at the same time he also decided he
couldn't go to the UN because China and
Russia were gonna veto anything we did
and then John Kerry who first off can we
have a national discussion about what
happened to his face really what
happened to his face then John Kerry in
seemingly a gaffe not his first gaffe
because he had also made a mistake at
the Security Council saying something
about having boots on the ground he
asked a question or was answering a
question about how Syria could get out
of this and he sort of offhandedly
remarked well if they give up all their
chemical weapons then we can probably
wrap this thing up I actually had
tweeted that a couple weeks ago but I'm
not sure he follows me anywho so now it
looks like we're not going to war and
President Obama addressed the nation
last night he even had a fancy graphic
that he tweeted out about it and let's
take a look over the last few days we've
seen some encouraging signs in part
because of the credible threat of US
military action as well as constructive
talks that I had with President Putin
the Russian government has indicated a
willingness to join with the
international community in pushing Assad
to give up his chemical weapons
the Assad regime has now admitted that
it has these weapons and even said they
joined the Chemical Weapons Convention
which prohibits their use it's too early
to tell whether this offer will succeed
in any agreement must have verify that
the Assad regime keeps its commitments
but this initiative has the potential to
remove the threat of chemical weapons
without the use of force particularly
because Russia is one of Assad's
strongest allies okay there you go so
Congress then cancelled their vote the
UN yesterday was supposed to vote on or
coming up with a resolution about this
Russian proposal that got cancelled - so
it's sort of an out for everybody Obama
doesn't have to go to an unpopular war
Congress doesn't even have to vote on it
the UN gets off at least for now
although that's probably gonna happen
sometime next week to me Russia seems
like the winner here and when I watch
that it's like it's a typical Obama like
I like what he's saying as usual and he
seems like a nice guy but I just have a
feeling that we seriously got played by
the Russians that they basically used
our military to get more influence in
the Middle East Jr do you what do you
think is the general is this a win for
the United States we did not go into a
war that nobody wanted yet it seems to
me we come out looking sort of like
we're Putin's pansies there's gonna be a
few popping up in Seattle yeah well I
think if I didn't see that perception
first and as I'm hearing it I can see
that point coming at the end of it I
don't care because the first thing we're
worried about the reason there was so
many people against it was I mean we're
looking at death we're looking at
unknowns and where we're launching
attacks we're looking at I don't know
another war in a quick aside back to the
9/11 talk where we're war tired you know
we're tired of this huge
and everyone keeps talking about how
we're a world war weary nation but is
that part of the is that sort of part of
the problem with American influence now
that maybe sometimes we can't now do the
right thing again I've been completely
against this war but that we can't do
the we can't save people you know even
the hundred thousand people that died
because the nation just doesn't want
yeah any Bush as you were saying the
first thing we think we're skeptical of
things that happen in our country now
because of what we've done even our own
citizens so we're a lot more alert about
what is going on okay so what exactly is
your proof John Kerry there's a few gaps
you had in there before we would have
listened so closely to what John Kerry
was saying we're like remember what
Coulomb ball said and we kind of just
glossed over and said oh it sounds
really bad let's go yeah now we're
thinking at the 15th minute of your
30-minute speech you said this this and
this how about you verify that where
we're on it more and maybe it saw a
bubble because this is what we do a lot
of people in America are looking or
listening 15 minutes into a John Kerry
so and things like don't cut out the
point that everyone needs to take in
that they couldn't listen to yeah and
maybe more I mean not only of course not
the larger teams I still think a lot of
Americans are completely uninformed but
we're it's a growing number when you
watch that do you feel that this was an
honest assessment of actually what
happened or that we just have to spin it
because Obama didn't really want it it
seemed like he really didn't want to do
this in the first place you know this
all of this just makes me angry I have
to say it's just so frustrating and so
annoying it's like these dudes it's all
men that have their stupid little
countries and their stupid power and
they're like pow pow I want to get you
oh I know it's in them Russians like no
serious my best friends I'm gonna bail
them out I know some was like 'wait
Putin you want to talk let's talk let's
do you want to do it's just it just
feels like a bunch of immature men that
have all this power they're playing a
board game of risk and everyone's lives
are at stake
and the as long as they look good it
doesn't matter like it just it
infuriates me and yet Russian the
at the only friend they have left it to
Syria everyone's like we hate Russia
yeah we hate America so yeah I agree
with you you know listen if Russia comes
out and they're like at the end of the
day you just I don't want to I don't
want us to be involved I don't and the
the Syrian people every single country
is horrible things are happening and we
keep going in and it never ends well and
so the thing overall I have to say
though Obama can't do anything right he
can't do anything right if he doesn't go
in the Republicans are gonna be we
should have gotten him if he goes then I
can't believe so the smartest thing he
did was to ask to go to Congress when I
heard that last Thursday I was like at
least at least you're protecting
yourself you're protecting yourself
because he cannot do anything right
isn't that crazy though how everything
is so political at the end of the day
like this is as Jenko he says he's just
a politician and everything is political
because for example we couldn't go to
the UN Security Council in the first
place because we know that Syria is
China Russia's best friend but now we're
kicking it back to the UN who's gonna
have to take care of the chemical
weapons so hasn't Obama sort of bungled
his own sort of like I want everything
to be international but now we're
kicking it back to an organization that
he knows doesn't really work
excellent stepped in actually stepped
into it going that direction he's going
well at least the blame is no longer
gonna be on me as you were saying he had
to worry about the redline talk yet then
there was the weakness or strength of
that banking himself up the political
side of it because he's dealing with a
you know a party that's 98 percent
against everything he does he has to
worry about that then he has to deal
with actually backing his words about
saying we're not trying to get into more
Wars all these things he's trying to
protect and when he saw a window of
opportunity he's like well there's gonna
be some negatives to hit on this but
let's go with it because yes the least
amount of negatives of course Congress
gets off the hook completely a group
with 15% approval that everybody
including me as I said wanted to have to
vote on this because I do believe in the
Constitution
that they don't even have to at the end
of the day they're not gonna have to do
anything well I mean listen it's it's
ugly all around but at the end of the
day if Russia's somehow or all of us
somehow get the chemical weapons out of
Syria I don't see this ending well and
like like open the door and be like our
chemical weapons are on the corner of
4th and main here's that here's the code
key just go in and clean them up and get
out and everything's gonna be fine and
then we'll what we'll we'll just we
won't gas everyone but we've got another
military stockpile of huge weapons and
we're just gonna continue to shoot
people so we'll get to that in one
second but yeah the idea that we're
gonna go into we or the UN or Russia or
whoever is gonna go into the middle of a
horrific Civil War and somehow walk out
of there with literally thousands of
tons of chemicals I'll be right back